[Music]
you don't know everything about me
i've lived a lot of lives
[Music]
before i was an avenger
before i got this family
i mean mistakes choosing
between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
[Music]
we have to go back to where it all
started
where did you think i was all this time
we have unfinished business
my girls are the toughest girls in the
world i'm sorry
we had our orders and we played our
wasn't real
it was real to me
to me you were everything
[Music]
[Music]
oh
one thing's for sure
[Music]
i'm done running for my past
[Music]
you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dress as a court justice it's
coming from a guy that wears a toilet
seat on his head we don't leave one of
our own behind hopefully harley's still
alive
no funny business these are dangerous
people team two is clear to go
fire uh three two what are you guys
doing
what you we're here to save you you were
gonna save
me it was a really good plan too well i
can go back inside and you can still do
it that's patronizing
i'm so sorry harley quinn bloodsport
[Music]
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission you get 10 years off your
sentence
[Music]
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
this is the famous suicide squad
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all gonna die i hope so
oh for [ __ ] sake here's the deal
we fail a mission you die we find out
any information you give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you die what no if you cough without
covering your mouth harley although that
isn't an
open invitation for you to cough without
covering your mouth
what's the plan how the hell am i
supposed to know you're the leader
you're supposed to be decisive and i've
decided that you should eat a big bag of
dicks
but this whole beach was completely
covered in dicks and somebody said i'd
eat every dick until the beach was clean
for liberty i would say no problem why
would someone put
penises all over the beans that's why
mad men do what they do
it's just suicide well that's kind of
our thing
[Music]
are you worried i'm gonna get you out of
your life i'm going to get you
out of here alive
[Applause]
oh my god we've got a freaking kaiju up
in this [ __ ]
like angels are splooting all over us
[Music]
oh
from your secret friend underneath
let's play a game just me and you
any of this mean anything to you
[Music]
you're becoming quite a celebrity
[Music]
why's he writing to you
if you are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
you're tired of this too
how am i part of this
you'll see
[Music]
all right so gave us a fake name again
again i'm not shocked
i just don't understand why he keeps
doing this you don't understand i feel
like it's pretty obvious to spoil things
i don't spoil things you're thinking
maybe one thing that i've actually
spoiled
the last kobe title
five thousand years ago kondok was a
melting pot of cultures
wealth power and magic
yet most of us had nothing except for
the chains
around our necks conduct needed a hero
instead they got me i did what needed to
be done
and they imprisoned me for it
[Music]
now 5000 years later
i'm free and i give you my word
no one will ever stop me again
michael i've known you since you were a
child
you have a gift you always have
if there's an old city a disease you'll
find it
i should have died in years
why ago i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this can be my last chance
[Music]
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
[Music]
strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
is an overpowering urge to consume blood
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbiel got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing huh
what's up guys
so
maybe one
he's back
[Music]
i spent a lot of time trying to divide
us
i made a promise to him on his grave
[Music]
i need to bring us together
there are enemies coming from far away
they serve an old power
this world is divided
no protectors here no lanterns
no kryptonium it will fall
in his name
[Music]
i have turned worlds to dusk
all of existence shall be
mine
i have a second chance i am not gonna
waste it
he said the age of heroes would never
come again
fighting the devil in his army
you know i don't care how many demons
has fallen how many hells he's never
fought us united
it's time to stand
[Music]
fight
the time is now
this world is not yet ready for all that
you will do
the time will come diana
and everything will be different
citizens of the world i'm here to change
your life
anything you want
anything you dream of you can have it
look like you saw a ghost
diana lucky you it's like now one day
has passed
i don't want to be like anyone i want to
be an
apex predator
you've always had everything while
people like me have had nothing
well now it's my turn
get used to it
i've never been one for rules the answer
is always
the more i fly they will never find us i
forgot to tell you
what radar will they will they shoot at
[Music]
[Applause]
us
[Music]
barbara what did you do
you know i'm not so keen on this one i
figure uh you are but
you know what i'm ready to go i think we
can do better
parachute pants yeah um does everybody
parachute now
can i help you why yes yes you can i'm
here to report a terrible crime
and what terrible crime is that
this one ah [ __ ] i told this all wrong
quick history lesson this all started
when the joker and i broke up
it was completely mutual
and soon enough i was back on my feet
ready to embrace the fierce goddess
within
[Music]
it's oh so quiet now that i cut ties
with mr j
i'm about to learn that a lot of people
want me dead uh
hello and at the top of that list is
this
um but it guy out
[Music]
that wasn't the only damon gotham
looking for emancipation
he's after all of us the kid just robbed
him
you betrayed him you killed his bff
what you are so cool
and you're dumb enough to be building a
case against him so unless we all want
to die
very unpleasant death we're gonna have
to work together
sure
psychologically speaking vengeance
rarely brings the catharsis we hope for
yeah are we ready
turn it up
[Music]
oh [ __ ] is that a hyena in a bathtub i
named him bruce after that hunky wayne
guys
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run
the reason you survived is because
you're a very
uncommon girl
you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are
would anyone like to share their first
time rain
i was 13. i thought it was a dream
i just lost control sam
i started panicking people got hurt
roberto my girlfriend that burned her
iliana i killed 18 men one
by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
[Applause]
i don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear
it makes you live through it until it
kills you
[Music]
he's there
we can get out of this together
they've taken control of most of europe
and russia
merciful heaven and invasion that's not
all mr president
i take it that's where your big idea
comes in let me introduce you the team
we said we would end this war
too many people have died
we can stop this
we need to utilize every metahuman we
can
you got there wonder woman i'm from the
future
it's not impossible
are you ready to end this war i thought
you'd never ask then welcome to the team
this goes haywire blame the new guy
turns out the nazis are launching a
surprise attack then we stop them
mother of god
a kid you ain't seen nothing yet
[Music]
you